let's go next to Joshua from Portugal
one of my favorite countries
in Western Europe Joshua from Portugal
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
honored to be back on after a long time
it's a pleasure
welcome I was just actually sorry no I
was just welcoming you
oh thank you I was just asking like it's
come it's more like these recent days
I'm looking more and more like an
American politics and I'm looking
outside as a European of course and I've
always like baffled confused and just
sad about everything that's going on and
compared to how Europe's going I feel
like worried for some of my friends who
live in the states What specifically
worries you
uh school shooting the rise of the far
rights far right such as sorry
um Maga the proud boys and all that jazz
it's so worrisome because if it's so
easy to just fix some of these issues
well coming from a European like school
shootings for example yes like the
recent school shooting that happened in
Florida a few days ago
it's kind of sad that I I'm gonna be
honest I'm always getting a little meld
out about it because of how it's a
constant thing it's hard no listen it's
hard not to get desensitized to anything
that's happening constantly because one
of the things humans do is we adapt and
uh I am I agree with you I am aware
myself of becoming desensitized to a lot
of the insane things that are going on
and to some degree it happens with the
shootings too
Joshua
all right Joshua's gone
um we could have delved more into it but
we lost Joshua let's continue here why
don't we go next to Ike from Lagos Ike
from Lagos welcome to the program
Ike are you with us here sir
Ike from Lagos welcome
Ike you probably have the law the wrong
audio device selected so let's see if
you could fix it because I would love to
speak to somebody from Lagos but it's
not clear if it's going to work for us
today
all right and a failure with Ike from
Legos let's go to I've I'm not familiar
with this name is it Juan fer from
Portland
hey David hi
yes uh I I live in Portland Oregon I'm a
I'm an immigrant from Quito Ecuador and
I love that you have a Spanish YouTube
channel thank you yeah we are we are
doing everything we can with it I know
some people are continuing to insist
that really I should be doing the the
Clips in Spanish I just don't have the
time but I did record a beautiful
message in Spanish which we will soon be
publishing on the channel explaining all
of it but I think the channel is coming
along nicely
so you know
um coming in into the U.S I have to
learn about the the political climate
here because in South America every
politician every bad politician every
even
every politician is from the left so we
have people like Rafael Correa and Petra
and Maduro which are really corrupt and
are making their countries
like you cannot live there anymore
the the salary in uh
in Venezuela
I'm sorry the salary of Venezuela is is
equivalent to four dollars a month
yes I'm aware of that now the purchasing
power is of course different
yeah so
um
I really like to thank you because you
have helped shape my political opinion
of how the the left is is helping
everybody in this country and underwrite
the Republicans are trying to stop
everything of value
I appreciate that uh I uh and doing what
I can to the extent that I am able but
it's going to take a lot more than just
me that's for sure so we've got to keep
building the movement and getting people
involved I think is the critical part
yeah well thank you Dave for team Nicole
all right thank you very much great to
hear from folks from all over the world
and all over the country we're going to
take a quick break but I am taking more
calls right after this short break so if
you're waiting to talk to me and you've
got a few more minutes just hang on
we'll go right back to the phones in a
moment